hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar cold PCR technology
current status and application in liquid
biopsies for cancer and prenatal
diagnosis
I'm Judy O'Rourke of laberd's and I'll
be moderating this session today the
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by PerkinElmer
PerkinElmer is a global leader committed
to innovating for a healthier world
they're optimized automated solutions
are designed to improve the efficiency
of genomic and proteomic workflows with
proprietary nucleic acid isolation
technology flexible liquid handlers
robust library preparation solutions
automated nucleic acid analysis and
protein characterization systems and
innovative solutions for single cell
genetic analysis PerkinElmer is
eliminating the challenges associated
with genomic and proteomic analysis to
learn more visit PerkinElmer - applied
genomics comm let's get started you can
post questions to the speaker during the
presentation while they're fresh in your
mind to do so simply type them into the
drop down box located on the far left of
your screen labeled ask a question and
click on the send button questions will
be answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
arrows at the top right hand corner of
the presentation window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support tab found at the top right
of the presentation window or report
your problem by typing it into the
answer question box located on the far
left of your screen this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I now
present today's speaker Mike gene
McCready Argos PhD dr. McReady or gose
is a professor and director of the
medical physics and biophysics division
in radiation oncology
dana-farber Cancer Institute and Brigham
and Women's Hospital Harvard Medical
School he also directs his DNA
technology laboratory in a radiation
preclinical facility his research
interests include the development of
novel DNA technologies for molecular
diagnostics in oncology and the
detection of circulating cancer
biomarkers funded continuously by NIH
over the last 25 years
he invented several new techniques for
molecular diagnostics including balanced
PCR cold PCR and named Pro he is a
member of the Editorial Board of
clinical chemistry and has published
over 150 articles in journals including
Nature Medicine Nature Biotechnology
nucleic acid research and clinical
chemistry
he received his undergraduate degree in
physics from the University of Athens
Greece is PhD in medical physics from
the University of Leeds UK and his
postdoctoral training in radiation
biology from Harvard Medical School
Boston dr. McReady or ghost will now
begin his presentation
yes good morning everybody thank you
very much for the introduction and I
would also like to thank the organizers
for inviting me through this webinar to
review the history and current
applications of Kohl PCR technology as
well as recent developments so we will
talk briefly about the significance of
detecting low-level mutations which is
what Colby fear does and go over the
qolt easier principles and early studies
as well as the most advanced version of
a technology called improved and
complete enrichment eyes eyes called PCR
and its principles and applications as
well as multiplexed eyes called PCR so
mutation detection as we all know has
numerous applications in cancer
diagnostics and personalized medicine
these low-level mutations are frequently
very frequently a potential problem in
in clinical samples from the point of
view that are always there they have
major clinical significance in many
cases but they are difficult to detect a
lot of technical difficulties so some
examples low level mutations are
encountered I would say in the majority
of clinical samples in cases that one
has infiltrating countries like
pancreatic infiltrating adenocarcinoma
in samples obtained from surgical
margins because there you only have
cases of mutations hopefully no
mutations at all but definitely you have
a high majority of wild-type containing
cells white type DNA containing cell
in bodily fluids about which we hear a
lot these days
liquid biopsies circulating tumor cells
always have high content of non cancer
cells as well containing Y type DNA in
non micro dissected samples in
colonoscopies where you want to detect
things like microsatellite instability
very early in the process you have an
excess of normal DNA as well and in
cases of genetic mosaicism but even more
so even in samples where you have the
majority of the cells being cancer cells
even when you still have interaction or
heterogeneity as this landmark paper
demonstrated back in 2012 it is from the
group offers one tells one Don in
England they sequenced different parts
of the tumor and it was found that
different mutations belong to different
sections of the tumor as well some
common mutations that uncle mutations
that are present in every cell so a lot
of intramural heterogeneity and that
obviously brings up both technical and
conceptual problems as to what is a
biopsy how much of the tumor molecular
profile does a biopsy capture now
thankfully things like liquid biopsy
have also grown recently and
demonstrated that there is circulating
DNA from the tumor in the blood which in
fact may represent
several parts of the tumor several sub
clones of a tumor as well as hidden
tumor and therefore this can provide
complementary information on the
molecular profile of a tumor
since many different sub clones may be
represented in a blood draw from which
one isolates circulating DNA and tumor
profile
now in addition to applications of
low-level mutations and liquid biopsy in
the field of cancer I would like to
mention that also in cases like in
medical applications like prenatal
diagnosis infectious diseases and in
detection of transplant rejection which
are all done via the technical aid in
DNA in blood again they we have the same
issue of few mutated DNA molecules in an
excess of Y type molecules so as you can
see them applications of low level
mutation detection are quite general and
they apply not only to cancer but also
to other fields that are emerging or
established
so there are several challenges however
technical challenges in measuring
circulating DNA and some of these are
shown here as we said you have rare
mutant copies in a wild-type background
DNA is highly fragmented in blood like
the majority is is a result of apoptosis
in tumor cells as well and normal cells
so that makes it highly fragmented and
low molecular weight typically 150 base
pair DNA or less but the difficulties
continue you have a limited number a
limited number of DNA molecules
nanograms per ml of plasma or blood so
as a resultant from a standard
collection of 10 to 20 milliliters of
blood you only get a few nano grams of
circulating DNA out of with to extract
the small portion that is useful
information the small portion that comes
from a tumor or from a fetus in the case
of prenatal diagnosis does have a few
precious nanograms to work with and as
we said earlier also tumors are
genetically heterogeneous so different
clones can set different amounts of
circulating DNA characterizing the
molecular profile of the clone so that
compounds the difficulties so
technologies that have been shown over
the last 10 years to do a good job in
characterizing say flight in DNA and
[Music]
measuring the molecular profile of the
tumor and NGS and digital PCR
among others these are two established
technologies and I have listed there the
basic characteristics of each one of
these two technologies below that as we
all know Andrea's is high parallel it
can be a discovery tool because you can
have a very very big net to cut fish in
there basically you can screen thousands
of genes gene targets at the same time
to discover new mutations depending on
what therapy is applied and and so on it
can also be a diagnostic tool when it is
used with focused panels and it's also
quantitative which is in some
applications is an important factor on
the other hand whatever we do is still
remains expensive even if the price is
reduced as we expect them it's still not
it's not going to be a cheap technology
like real-time PCR for example or
digital PCR and it still takes time to
analyze the results and you need an
instrument or a core facility to perform
that for you on the other hand digital
PCR it is wonderful from the point of
view of absolute quantification it is
very reliable but it can only do one or
a few targets at a time and again you
need an instrument so today I am going
to talk about Cole PCR which is an even
more flexible technology to use and to
adapt to various clinical scenarios and
which can be applied on a standard
real-time PCR or standard PCR instrument
which is available in every lab so our
approach through the years has been to
apply
enrichment of mutations prior to their
detection as you can see here you have
many of Y time molecules and few mutant
molecules entering the funnel and then
by applying Col PCR one can indeed the
mutant and then the endpoint detection
method is becoming much easier to
perform so kool PCR has been around now
for ten years so it's a good anniversary
10th year anniversary of the technology
and in a big view a helicopter view of
what has happened these 10 years is that
several papers have been published I'm
only listening here I would say them the
main papers that have driven the
technology although it has been
translated to many different
applications by different groups there
is more than a thousand references in
the literature in called PCR if you
check MEDLINE and there is at least 50
different groups around the world that
had usually have used it closing for
their own needs and adapted it and in
terms of a commercial application the
technology has been licensed to trans
anomic recipient companies that have met
now for the most advanced version of the
technology which is the LNA based icicle
PCR or ICP about which we'll talk
tomorrow later on today
so here is the principle of cold PCR as
it was originally published and it's
important to understand that in order to
understand the later versions of the
technology so upon denaturation at 94
degrees
the two strands of DNA are separated and
then instead of going all the way down
to a temperature to which the primers
will bind we stop at an intermediate
temperature like 70 to 75 degrees 70
degrees that allows the top and bottom
strands of DNA to bind with each other
without yet the primers initiating
synthesis because we keep the
temperature high enough so that the
primers don't bind so obviously if you
use a hybridization at 70 degrees the
Primus should not appreciably bind up 70
degrees in order for this to work at the
hybridization temperature of say 70
degrees that top and bottom strands will
bind and if you have mutant that is more
likely to hybridize with wild-type DNA
because this is in excess and then you
create a small bubble and this bubble
contains mutant on one side and white
type on there on the SI on the bottom
strand and you also create a lot of
white type while type Homo duplexes then
by increasing the temperature by a few
degrees to a critical temperature that
differentiates between homo duplexes and
hetero duplexes you achieve preferential
denaturation of the hetero duplexes so
here you denied your mutant and wild
type strands the homo duplex has
remained hybridized and following that
then we reduce the temperature to say
binding temperature of 60 degrees the
primers bind preferentially into the
denatured homo duplexer
is the mutant and we synthesize
preferentially the mutant sequences and
then we continue this process 2030
cycles and the enrichment is gradually
compounded compounded and the result is
that at the end then that effect the
generated PCR product contains a much
higher mutant sequence as opposed to Y
type relative to what we started what is
important to note is that the mutation
enrichment occurs at all positions on
the sequence it doesn't matter where the
bubble will form you will always have
some enrichment which can be different
from position to position
but in all cases you get an advantage
and you increase the sensitivity of
mutation detection this is this makes
called PCR distinct to other
technologies that utilize and changes in
the primer sequence like at the end of
the primer you can have a lil specific
PCR that enriches for mutations that are
right on the three prime end and that is
another way to enrich mutations which
however work only for one position at
the end of a primer here you can have
150 200 base pairs of amplicon and
irrespective where the mutation is it
will be enriched so as a result called
PCR can be combined with technologies
and point technologies for mutation
detection that detect mutations anywhere
on the sequence and that's the only
technology that can do that like
sequencing for example or high
resolution melting
so as as you see here since PCR is
performed tired to almost all methods
for mutation detection like a tower ATM
die dog sequencing pyrosequencing NGS in
most in many cases you perform some PCR
step RFLP and so on if you replace the
initial step with called PCR you
increase the sensitivity of all these
methods in Multan Aslam
so let's look at some examples
improvement of sequencing sensitivity so
this is some results from the original
publication where we have a mutation in
p53 and in on the left side you see if
you perform regular PCR followed by
Sanger sequencing the mutation is hardly
visible if you perform cold PCR with the
naturalization or critical temperature
86 point five the mutation is enriched
and it can be seen and the same thing
from plasma circulating DNA in the
middle section regular PCR on the life
you can't see the mutation but you can
see it it becomes heterozygous
essentially if you perform cold PCR and
the same thing at the bottom using
clinical FFP specimens from lung cancer
patients you can barely see the mutation
with regular PCR but you can see it's
very evident with Cole TCR so
irrespective of where the mutation is it
will be enriched now you may ask you may
ask the obvious thing what if you do one
round of cold PCR and then you do a
second round of cold PCR and nested step
four called PCR and with the enrichment
increases even more and the answer is
yes as you see from that paper back in
human mutation back in 2009 with regular
PCR you don't see the mutation that was
a very low-level mutation
that we applied here even one round of
coal pcr here does not so the mutation
two rounds will eventually so the
mutation without changing the profile of
all the other sequences and that's
important to state that during called
PCR since you are doing and continue
cycling you may have a polymerase
introduced error so if an error is
introduced failure cycle 5 then this
false mutation will also be enriched
during cold Vizia so eventually if you
keep doing too much called PCR you will
produce false positives because of
polymerase miss incorporation here we
demonstrated by having a proofreading
enzyme that up to two rounds of cold PCR
you don't see appreciable generation of
mutants at least at the level that we
can see by Sanger sequencing so bottom
line two rounds of called PCR increase
the enrichment even more
and an application now of cold PCR in
conjuction with with sequencing in this
case what we did is we had two rounds of
cold PCR and as a control experiment on
the Left who had two rounds of
conventional PCR with exactly the same
primers and then we went ahead and
sequenced using the high 6 mm and that
was back in 2011 that we performed this
study and what what we saw here is
essentially the limits of sequencing by
using conventional PCR a 2% mutation can
still be seen over the sequencing noise
but we get by using the standard
protocol that comes from Illumina while
with 1% we are close to the noise okay
so basically that the limits of standard
sequencing unless one applies the newest
development using molecular barcodes but
I'm talking now about the standard
application that comes with commonly
used protocols if on the other hand one
applies called PCR before going to the
standard Illumina sequencing that's what
you get you increase the signal while
keeping the background approximately the
same and that you can see that you can
go all the way down to 0.02 percent of
Cole PCR and still discriminate over the
background okay so by enriching the
signal you increase the signal-to-noise
ratio so you can detect while you're
sequencing the lower level mutations and
unimportant
point to notice here is that you just
need a small sequencing depth you can
see here that in the extreme case we
detect a 0.02 percent mutation with just
28 reads sequencing reads
which is impossible unless one does some
enrichment of the mutants
by enriching the mutants you bring them
to a high enough level that 28 AIDS are
enough to solve a signal so two
advantages increasing the
signal-to-noise ratio and a reduction in
the number of sequencing reads that you
need
so another application is them the
improvement in real-time pcr and we use
TaqMan here and perform called PCR what
we have is two TaqMan probes one that
matters the mutant and one that matters
the wild-type sequence and we perform
them Tuchman real-time PCR
under cold pcr poor conditions the
cycling conditions are as I explained
earlier in the cold PCR principle and
here is a comparison there on the top
panel you see a conventional TaqMan
genotyping of t 790 EGFR resistance
mutation and under these approach with
conventional TaqMan you can just
differentiate about 12% mutant to white
type from the signal that you get from
pure wild-type
you cannot go any lower if you apply the
very same time as the very same probes
using Cole PCR cycling then you can go
down 2.8% mutant to wild-type and this
actually comes to be a very quantitative
test so if you are talking about
applying cold PCR on the same mutation
every time in real time you can get a
straight line like you get for regular
PCR versus concentration of the original
sample and mutation evidence of the
original sample I have some examples on
that later
next is the improvement of high
resolution melting by using called PCR
try or - melting now high resolution
melting as you know is one of the most
commonly used methods for mutation
detection because of them reliability
and the ease of use and a very low cost
these days a lot of PCR instruments come
with a standard high resolution melting
mode so obviously application with poor
vision is something we wanted to
consider here especially since called
PCR and ridges mutations anywhere in the
sequence and a tram detects mutations
anywhere on the sequence by using
mutation scanning aids are M so the two
technologies work together very well so
what you see here is at the top
a serial dilutions of samples that have
10% mutant 8% mutant 6% mutant and so on
serial dilution with conventional aider
and conventional pcr followed by
standard HRM and you can see that the
limit of the texture is 3 to 5% here
depending also on what mutations you
have so that's the standard technology
if you apply called PCR you get a very
significant improvement in the LOD the
lower limit of detection 0.1 to 0.5% can
be detected very easily and importantly
one is able to sequence the product
because although ATM is very easy to use
and
basically very low cost and low effort
it won't tell you where the mutation is
and if you try to sequence it very often
you can't find for example in the
conventional ATM a 5% mutation may be
detected by ATM but then you can
sequence it by using Sanger by doing
enrichment you can both detect lower
level and sequence them the engagement
is big enough that you can see it on
Sankar so that that was also early work
Cole PCR HRM overall is the easiest way
to exploit the technology immediately as
I called PCR you perform HRM without
necessarily having to open the tube
there is no new instruments the reagents
needed in most cases there is no need to
change primers and it enables increase
in sensitivity in sequencing so I would
recommend to anybody who wants to start
using Cole PCR to combine it first with
HRM to make sure everything works okay
even as a quality control test so I
compiled here in number of reports on
called PCR over the last 10 years that
have been applied applied in different
fields for detection of mutations in
tumor margins treatment assessment
colorectal cancer circulating tumor
cells but beyond cancer prenatal
diagnosis crop improvement drug arrest
and mutations mosaic mutations and so on
as well as modifications of called PCR
technology to be applied in DNA damage
detection as opposed to mutation
detection so most of these have used HRM
them the majority not all but a tram
again is the easiest way to exploit the
technology followed by sequencing if you
see a positive in there on HRM so now
let's move to the more advanced part of
the technology is called PCR improved
and complete enrichment we developed
that in 2011 and why we developed it we
noticed that in the early cycles of PCR
it is more difficult to form a hetero
duplex because you have very low levels
of your template
so in the first ten cycles when you
stand from genomic DNA you have very
very few molecules so they can find each
other in solution the hetero duplex
doesn't form so for this reason we
thought let's help the situation and add
a reference sequence which is
essentially does the wild-type sequence
which by itself cannot be amplified by
the primers you don't want to amplify
the reference sequence what you wanted
to do isn't in any PCR cycles since it
has a high concentration it will offer
y-type template to bind with your few
mutant molecules in early PCR cycles so
by adding an excess of reference
sequence in the solution we help
hybridization and hetero duplex
formation at early PCR cycles and then
the process produce produces unimproved
and complete enrichment and that's why
we called it is called visual now the
other thing of course is that the since
you are including a synthetic reference
sequence you can synthesize it either
from an oligonucleotide synthesizer or
or via PCR like we did in the original
paper you can always include modified
bases in there and in some cases
modified bases like lock nucleic acid or
DNA peptide nucleic acid or other
similar modifications can give you an
advantage because they create a bigger
difference between hetero duplexes and
homo duplexes to make a long story short
that led to the
LNA based ice called PCR which we often
for convenience we call it ICP that's
the most advanced version of a
technology and produces the best
enrichment and I have here some data
that was presented by Richardson and
co-workers at ASCO batting back in 2011
that is the first report on the LNA
based ice core PCR or ICP you can see
detection of b-raf mutations in melanoma
and here in a serial dilution study you
can see that the detection is easily
down to zero point zero two zero zero
five percent mutant to wild-type and
here is the same application for EGFR X
19 deletions for deletions the
technology works particularly well
because as you can imagine a deletion or
an insertion makes an even bigger hetero
duplex difference than a single point
mutation and one can sequence through
the deletion after you enrich to the
extent that called PCR does so it as you
can see here a very nice sequencing
through the deletion
that was presented in 2012 and then in
2013 the group of your toast in France
also independently developed the an LNA
based ice called PCR which they called E
is called PCR it essentially the same or
very similar to what I described they
have done an excellent worker working
out a number of
advantages of his technology and I have
some slides that were kindly provided by
York toast to show you in some of the
next slides
so here you see the comparison on the
left of conventional PCR to have three
cancer samples in one white title and in
the middle we have Cole PCR and on the
right we have ice called PCR and as you
can see there are cases that
conventional PCR and the originally
developed called PCR don't solve the
mutation it is a very low-level mutation
but it becomes clearly evident with ICP
or ice called PCR yeah at the same time
the Y type remains wild-type that's
always important to verify in seeds and
such sensitive technologies
so one question that many people ask and
we also are through the years is how do
you quantify the original mutation
evidence when you create this enrichment
of Cole vision which can be different
from mutation to mutation and from point
to point in an amplicon which is a
hundred and fifty base pair long how do
you find the original mutation evidence
this is not always necessary but in some
cases some applications like monitoring
for minimal residual disease can be
important so that you know how the tumor
dynamics are developing so here is a
serial dilutions for five different
mutations using is called PCR and what
we have plotted here at the x and x axis
is the amount of alteration in the
starting sample right so this is what
you want to find out what is the amount
the mutant allele ik frequency in the
starting sample and on the y-axis is the
resulting frequency after Cole PCR and
as you can see here if you take any
given mutation just concentrate on the
green color for example you can plot a
nice relatively good straight line for
the same mutation on the same amplicon
but for different mutations the
enrichment is different so the relation
is different so it is not possible to
have a single relation that will tell
you what the enrichment is irrespective
of where in the sequence it has taken
place but for a given mutation like for
example 8790 you can very easily relate
them obtain a final mutation in
men to their original alteration so its
quantitative only if you consider one
mutation at a time
and again this is a slide that we
received by York toss group in France
who has done detailed such studies they
have compared that to digital vision so
they took individual mutations and they
they compared to quantification that
they get with ice called PCR as compared
to digital PCR and as you see at the
bottom in the three graphs that are
presented here you have nice straight
lines in all cases as long as the
enrichment you obtain is calibrated via
a serial dilution curve it doesn't
change anymore and one can apply that to
clinical samples for a given mutation at
the time and you get results that are
not very different from digital PCR of
course digital PCR is an absolute
quantification method ice-cold PCR is a
relative quantification method you need
to create the standard curve because
before you read something like this
okay so and here is a combination of ICP
LNA based PCR and Packman at the same
time again showing essentially the same
thing on one hand that you can detect
down to 0.01% mutation depending also on
which mutation of course but at the same
time that you get a reasonably good
straight line considering them and
considering the enrichment effect so the
take-home method is that if you restrict
it to a given mutation you can apply
quantitative ice called PCR
and this is what we did in this study so
in this study we asked the question what
level of mutilations is clinically
significant in the particular case of
meal or dysplastic syndrome so that's a
collaboration we did with been a Bert
and Raphael bazaar here at dana-farber
and with Katherine Richardson at Rand
anomic we wanted to see if low-level and
Russ mutations can predict who will
recur and who will progress to leukemia
which is a common development of malar
dysplastic syndromes
so whenever General in their studies
have shown that n res mutations are
prognostic but we didn't know what about
a very low level of enough mutation what
level of mutation should we be worried
that so we applied a study using
highschool PCR to detect the very low
level mutations here are the results
with green 295 samples using either
standard called PCR sequencing or is
called PCR followed by sequencing and
the conventional PCR using multi or
Sanger detected Andras mutations and as
anticipated is called PCR followed by
NGS using ion torrent in this case
detected many more mutations at very low
frequency then we asked the question are
these clinically significant and
quantification as I mentioned before can
be done for individual mutations by
doing a serial dilution study and
setting up essentially calibration
curves here is what you see for
three different andraz mutations that's
what we use for quantification and we
drew our calibration curves and here is
the comparison with the clinical results
the kaplan-meier curves and what we
demonstrated is that if the ice called
PCR detected mutations are of the order
of 0.1 to 0.2% there is no difference
they they have no relevance for
developing to leukemia to AML basically
so they are not clinically significant
however if they are more than 2 percent
or 0.5 percent which was shown to be the
threshold there is clinical significance
and it was shown in this and papers that
will confer an independent prognostic
factor so here is a case that one needs
to detective mutations quantitatively
you can do it with ICP or potentially
you can also do it with digital PCR okay
if you have the instrument and the level
of significance is 0.5% in this case so
the level of significance obviously
depends on the conditions you are
studying so it will be different for
every different study
so further applications of the ICP
technology with liquid biopsies are
listed here for anyone that has time to
read that basically but many nice
studies have been sown with recently and
they keep increasing for application of
high school PCR with liquid biopsies in
several clinical situations the three
first papers at the topper for cancer
where the two papers below that are for
prenatal diagnosis now for prenatal
diagnosis in particular what one is
interested is to detect them eternally
inherited mutations in maternal blood
that's what the technology is good for
because these are going to be low-level
mutations and you need to enrich them
and the tagline was confidence so the
first paper was basically published by
gal Piatti
and co-workers group in Italy 2011 and
the most recent papers have been some
intermediate papers but the most recent
papers were published 2018 by my
collaborators in Cyprus where they were
applied to detecting paternal inherited
mutations in beta thalassemia
so the last few minutes that I remaining
I would like to mention the latest
developments of a technology
multiplexing ice called PCR multiplexing
I Scalzi a PCR was first reported by the
group of York toaster in France and and
where they demonstrated multiplexing of
three different amplicons here be rough
chaos and andrás and the technology
retains the sensitivity for all three
amplicons at the time so you have three
reference sequence working at the same
time and with a single thermal cycling
protocol so in collaboration with
priciple we have also been working and
developing Sattler systems and what you
see here is multiplexing or for
amplicons for EDF file actions 18 to 21
what we have a sample collection DNA
isolation multiplex is called PCR and at
that point we demonstrated that a high
resolution melting screening can be very
beneficial to tell you if there is a
mutation in any of the four amplicons
if there is not you can stop patron is
indeed very reliable so it will save you
the work and expense going to end point
detection so here is an example we
demonstrated that a number of different
carriers mutations can be differentiated
down to very low levels point one point
zero five percent from wild-type with
HRM
prior to doing any other endpoint
detection so you don't know where the
mutation or which type of the mutation
is there but you know there is a
mutation and by performing HRM after is
called PCR all in a single tube you
don't need to open the tube necessarily
you already know if there is a mutation
anywhere on this sequence and the same
thing for the other sequences at the
same time and now if it is shown by
eight around that there is a mutation
how do you find the mutation you can
either perform sequencing or like we
demonstrate here you can perform a
second PCR and nested PCR for each
individual mutations by applying a
standard Tuchman real-time PCR so that
now will tell you exactly which mutation
you have so you have a series of
reactions each one testing for
interrogating one particular mutation
and that is a very reliable application
and here we basically demonstrated that
Sanger sequencing also works after
multiplexing before EGFR amplicons exon
18 EXO 19 one can go down to very low
levels standard PCR on the left is
called PCR on the right you don't see
the mutation on the left you see it on
the right and about section 20 and
action 21 so these data were provided by
me by been lured gentle and grant who
had recipient who are our collaborators
developing these assays so in summary
the Colt easier technology is very
versatile it enables sensitive
sequencing for personalized medicine
you don't need an
instrument you get the high sensitivity
at very little cost essentially it
enables higher mutation sensitivity for
every downstream technology you choose
whether it is NGS or real-time PCR
pyrosequencing or other not specialized
instrumentation rapid sample to result
in multiplexing capability which is a
matching application of the order of 2
to 10 targets that way we see the
usefulness if you go to even more
targets basically you can potentially
choose NGS if you want one target you
can potentially do dd PCR if you have
the instrument but for targets that you
want to get to the answer rapidly
without much expense potentially before
you do NGS and we see that is called PCR
is a good solution and because of the
flexibility we can see also application
of called PCR in microfluidic all-in-one
devices that are now coming basically to
the common use for very fast PCR within
minutes you can get sample to result so
in the bottom here I have listed all the
various specimens that one can examine
and have spat on other bodily bodily
fluids that could be urine of course and
liquid biopsies and I would like to
thank you for your attention and thank
my collaborators as well as the people
at the lab over the last several years
that did this work thank you for your
attention
dr. McReady or goes for your
presentation a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them into the drop down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
dr. McReady or goes full answers many
questions as time permits first question
is how can you determine the level of
enrichment due to cold PCR so your qPCR
result actually tells you what frequency
the mutation is yes so I hope that some
of my slides that perhaps were presented
after the question was was paused answer
this one essentially how do you quantify
the original mutation Abaddon's and
again if you have a particular mutation
in mind that you are interested to
quantify you have to run a serial
dilution to create a calibration curve
you only do that once for it amplicon
and for each mutation you only need to
do that once it is some work but that
how you you calibrate your final
mutation enrichment and based on the
original mutation evidence and this is
what you do if you want to do it with
two PCR essentially that's what you do
you need to do so it's a similar process
the only technology that you avoid doing
that is digital PCR because that's an
absolute quantification but in most
other situations including called PCR
each mutation needs its own standard
curve let's say thank you how does one
identify the critical denaturation
temperature used in the cotton yarns are
most likely protocol yeah yes so this is
the most commonly asked question and
basically about kool PCR so you need to
run a gradient for every amplicon for
every amplicon that you're going to
Griffen you need to run a gradient of
reactions at different denaturation
temperatures and choose the correct one
if you are running ice-cold PCR in the
presence of LNA containing reference
sequence you have a big range to play
with like as long as you are within
three to four degrees from the best
critical denaturalization temperature
you get good enrichment basically now if
you are using cold PCR as it was
originally described without the
reference sequence there you need to be
much more precise you need it better
than 0.5 degrees so you need a very fine
temperature gradient with different in
iteration temperatures and out of those
you need to select those that lead to
best enrichment as detected with say
Sanger sequencing or another technology
digital PCR for better accuracy now that
may seem as a lot of work but you only
do that once and for every mutation
along the sequence you always get the
good enrichment at a single denaturation
temperature you don't need to do that
for every mutation you get good at it
when you can find good and critical
temperature that provides good
enrichment along the entire sequence by
doing this gradient approach thank you
next one is are you performing
high-resolution melting right after most
multiplex PCR on all amplicons at the
same time
yes this is correct like in multiplex
PCR approaches where all amplicons
enriched mutations at the same time you
have essentially a new way to apply a
terrain because ATM so far has been
applied on one amp liquid at a time but
if you have a technology that provides
engagement on all of them at the same
time you can perform HRM on all four
amplicons or ten amplicons at the same
time I would say the limit is about five
to ten amplicons in this approach ATM
becomes a very strong tool for a few
applicants that are enriched all at the
same time thank you looks like we have
time for one more question
how many amplicon max can you include
simultaneously any multiplexed ice-cold
pcr protocol
yeah essentially as many as you can
optimize there is no limit now we are
developing approaches that can go to 30
40 50 amplicons
but of course if you are if you are
going to go to some many mutation so
many amplicons your end points would
probably be NGS if you are going to do
it fast and up the end and easily at low
expense by using technologies like a
time I would say the maximum is five to
ten mutations so the limitation comes
from the HRM side here not from the core
PCR side I would like to once again
thank dr. Matt reader goes for his
presentation I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration we would like to thank our
sponsor PerkinElmer for underwriting
today's educational webcast this webcast
can be viewed on-demand through May 20
nineteen hundreds will alert you via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live events until next time
goodbye
you